اعلن الاسطول الخامس الامريكي نشره ثلاثه
الاف جندي وعدد من القطع البحريه في الشرق
الاوسط كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات ما الاهداف التي تسعى واشنطن
لتحقيقها بارسال كل هذه التعزيزات
العسكريه الى الشرق الاوسط على اي نحو
يمكن ان ينعكس تعزيز واشنطن وجودها
العسكري في المنطقه على منظومه امنها وما
المالات المحتمله لامن الخليج في ضوء
ارتفاع التوتر بين طهران واشنطن على خلفيه
هذه التحركات
[موسيقى]
لارسال رساله الى طهران بان اجراء اي
هجمات على السفن او على المؤسسات
سيواجه
برد سريع وقوي تصعيد هو امريكي وليس
ايراني لان ايران عندما
ناقلاتي احتجزت ذلك في اطار رد الفعل على
احتجاز ناقله ايرانيه في جنوب شرق اسيا
وسرقت نفطها من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انه ليست الولايات المتحده هي
التي تختطف السفن ليست لولايات المتحده
التي
ترسل المصاريخ تسقط على على مواقع مختلفه
مختلف الدول المنطقه اذا ايران هي
المحفز والمؤدي الى كل هذا الوضع وتعزيز
لما هو موجود وليس حشد قوه بمعنى حشد
القوه يوجد في المنطقه الاسطول الخامس
قيادته في البحرين في المنام
يوجد به حامل الطائرات يوجد به 17 قطعه
بحريه قتاليه اصلا يوجد 3500 يوجد اكثر من
70 طائره يوجد عشرات الطائرات العموديه
تعزيز القوه بقطعتين بحريتين قوه البشريه
بثلاث الاف جندي من المشات واشنطن تشعر
بقلق نتيجه بعض الخطوات التي
تتخذتها طهران خلال الشهر الماضيه
ومنها
تردد ايران في الدخول اي مفاوضات جاده
هاجمت مصالح الولايات المتحده وغيرها في
المنطقه
اننا تركنا طهران
اتواصلت تهديداتها ونشاطاتها العسكريه
فانا فعلا المنطقه ستعرض المزيد الاخلال
بالاستقرارها هناك تنامي في القوه يعني من
وجهه النظر الامريكيه تنامي في التهديد
يعني مناورات هي حق طبيعي مكتسب لكل الدول
لرفع الكفاءه القتاليه ولا اتصور ان
الموضوع يستفز الاخر نعم ايران الان تمتلك
صواريخ الكروز بمدى الف كيلو متر الان نعم
ايران تمتلك قوه رادحه وتحاول ان تستعملها
وتحاول ان تستعرضها لمنع الحرب عقب
المواجهه المفتوحه على جنى كلا الجانبين
ثقيل جدا وان كانت على الجانب الايراني
اكثر كسوه الان هي رسائل ردع ورسائل تحذير
قل لن تحدث مواجهه مفتوحه لجمله اسباب
فارق القوه في المستوى والسياق
الاستراتيجي ما بين البحريه الايراني
والبحريه الامريكيه بنك القوه الرئيسي لا
يسمح لايران بمواجهه مفتوحه شامله وان هذه
الناقلات المدنيه تعرض خطر هجوم كما حصل
في ما حصل مع من القراصنه فاذا هناك ضروره
لخلق مثل هذه البقاع الحمائيه حول
الناقليه تستطيع ان تمر بامان في مياه
البحر الدوليه
[موسيقى]
هو نيران تحاول زياده الضغوط على واشنطن
وعلى دول المنطقه طاف لكي تحصل على نوع من
التخفيف العقوبات عليها توتير الاجواء
يدفع دول المنطقه
للعوده تحت المظله الامنيه الامريكيه
ويمنع التفلت الذي حصل خلال السنوات
الماضيه
باتجاه روسيا والصين من قبل بعض الدول في
المنطقه بعد دارت ترامب جاءت اداره بايدن
وهي تتطلع الى سعاده الحياه نفاق النووي
مع ايران ولكن طهران كانت بصراحه غبيه
بصراحه بطريقه تعاملها مع تلك المفاوضات
علينا ان نفهم ان القوات العسكريه
الامريكيه لا غير منتشره بشكل هجومي ولا
يستطيعون كيف يمكن الصعوده الى
ظهر السفن الايرانيه بل فقط طريقه حمايه
حلفائنا ايران لن تبدا اي حرب مع اي طرف
في المنطقه حتى امريكا طيب باستثناء
الكيان الصهيوني